this is really what we have to start
with i'm afraid and it's not appropriate
for children
or or for anyone frankly but jeffrey
toobin
cnn legal analyst obviously as you know
showed his tube during a zoom call with
colleagues a few months ago
in fact you know he was he didn't just
show it he was uh he was you know
handling
the situation so to speak right there in
front of everybody on the zoom call
and uh it really kind of rubbed everyone
the wrong way as you might imagine and
he was fired for or not fired
it you you'd think that you would be
fired for that
masturbating you know workplace
masturbation
the kind of thing that you would think
would get you fired especially in the
metoo era
well that's not what happened because
he's back now he was back on cnn
yesterday
and they for some reason decided to
on tv have a conversation
about tubin's masturbatory habits
and they brought a woman in allison
camerata to have this discussion
this is i think the most cringe-inducing
thing
to ever air on cable news
i mean it's oh i actually have not seen
this entire video yet
because i can't get past 15 seconds it
is so
it the cringe is overwhelming it's
nuclear grade
cringe this is a cringe comet
um an absolute volcano an explosion of
cringe well
i'm gonna stop on that i'm not gonna go
any further with that analogy anyway
let's uh let's try we're just gonna try
to watch this
and see how far we can make it let's
go ahead here in october you
were on a zoom call with your colleagues
from the new yorker magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which time
you were caught masturbating on camera
okay stop can you stop
i can't i can't go any further
why are they doing this and why is he
sitting there i'm asking why
rhetorically i know all the answers to
my questions but so
why is he sitting there enduring this
embarrassment
i know he wants his job back and
everything but he's been how old's this
guy
he's probably in his 60s now he's been
on tv a long time doesn't have money
saved up
how could you ever how are you showing
your face again and
imagine this guy walking through the
hallways of cnn
he ends up in a break room grabbing a
coffee with someone that was on that
zoom call like hey
how you been why would you want to
endure that there's no amount of money
that could make that worth it go off
into the into the woods
grow your beard out you know you you can
have all you just you do everything
you're out of sight do everything go
ahead and do what you need to do out
there
and live out the rest of your days
all right let's we're gonna keep going
we're gonna try to make it through this
you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn
do i have all that right um you got it
all right sad to say
okay so let's start there um to quote
jay leno
what the hell were you thinking well
obviously
i wasn't thinking very well or very much
and
um it was something that was
inexplicable to me i think one point i
wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't think
other people could see me you thought
that you had turned off your camera
correct
i thought that i had turned off the zoom
call now that's not a difference
okay wait stop it there first of all
inexplicable his own masturbation was
inexplicable to him
what does what does that even mean
he's looking down at himself going what
what's going on right now
and then he says he didn't know that his
co-workers could see him
so what he's saying is yeah i was i was
masturbating in front of my coworkers i
didn't but i didn't know they could see
me
and that makes it okay
all right how long is this video let's
just
let's just let's just make it through go
ahead this was
deeply moronic and indefensible
but i mean that that is part of that
that is part of the story
um and you know i have spent the seven
subsequent months miserable months in my
life i can certainly
confess um trying to be a better person
i'm miserable therapy
i think trying to i think people who had
to see that jeffrey working in a food
bank which i certainly am going to
continue to do
working on a new book about the oklahoma
city bombing but i
am trying to become the kind of person
that people can trust again working in a
food bank i don't want this guy handling
my food
but people that are going to a food bank
they've they're having a hard enough
time now they got a chronic public
masturbator
serving their food
oh man the whole thing is
is i don't even know what to say
probably i've said too much
as it is but let's can we be clear about
about one thing
okay as cnn tries to well a couple
things to be clear about
cnn's trying to rehabilitate this guy
because he's one of their own
right um this they would never do this
right if this wasn't someone that they
had a personal attachment to they would
never do this
almost anybody else their life is over
for this
certainly you you lose your job for that
like this is take me two out of it take
cancel culture
out of it in any normal scenario
you take your pants off and do that in
front of co-workers
you're gonna lose your job and you're
not gonna get it back
it doesn't matter what era we're living
in it doesn't matter anything you're
gonna lose your job for that
but cnn's going to rehabilitate why is
louis c.k
is still persona non grata he's he's
still in exile from
polite society how do you justify that
if jeffrey toobin is allowed to come at
least louisa kaye got consent first
before he did that
jeffrey tuban didn't ask anybody
but also another thing to be clear about
is yes
and somehow this has been lost in the
whole conversation
he didn't know his camera was on i i
believe that he didn't know the camera
was on i think that much was clear
but he was on a zoom call
in a work meeting and he knew that
so he is doing that his plan
was to do that while watching
this meeting right he was he was trying
to do that during a meeting
that part was intentional the
unintentional part was that the camera
was on
so i go back to how is that not a a
permanently fireable offense
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content